إذن ما هي نصيحتك للأشخاص
الذين يرغبون في السفر بالطائرة هذا الصيف، مع العلم أنه
كما تقول قد يصبح الأمر قبيحًا نوعًا ما،
بالتأكيد لا أعتقد أنه يجب على الناس تجنب
الطيران بشكل عام، يجب عليهم بالتأكيد
الاستفادة من
إجازتهم المستحقة.  الوقت الذي تقضيه
مع الأصدقاء والعائلة أو تعلم
القيام برحلة التذاكر الكبيرة التي
ربما لم يقوموا بها في
السنوات القليلة الماضية بسبب الوباء، ومرة ​​أخرى
لا توجد كرة بلورية لتقول نعم،
سيتم إلغاء رحلتك  متأخرة
أو غير ذلك، ولكن هناك بعض الأشياء
التي يمكنك القيام بها لتمنح نفسك
أفضل الاحتمالات، وهي أن تقوم
برحلة صباحية تتمتع
بوقت أداء أعلى بنسبة 25 نقطة مئوية مقابل
القيام برحلة بعد الظهر، حيث أن رحلتك
لا تأتي من مكان آخر، بل
بالفعل في المطار، لذا فإن احتمالية
تأثره بالطقس أو
التأثيرات الخارجية أقل بكثير من
بداية اليوم مقارنة بتأخره،
كما حاول القيام برحلة طيران بدون توقف
سبع إلى ثماني مرات أكثر احتمالية
لإيصالك إلى وجهتك في  الوقت مقابل
رحلة متصلة والتي يمكن أن
تؤثر على الرحلة الأولى مما يؤثر بعد ذلك على
رحلتك الثانية، لذلك يكون
تأثير الدومينو تقريبًا